something happens to you when you leave
this town farther way the easier it all
gets the me and I've left I remember all
of it
[Applause]
[Music]
to the losers we made an oath I swear if
it isn't dead if it ever comes back
we'll come back to you we didn't stop it
the cloud we can't let it happen again
[Music]
for 27 years
I dreamt of you
[Music]
I'll miss you
we need to finish it
[Music]
it consumes us from the inside until we
don't have a choice anymore
[Music]
happy comic-con week everybody so they
dropped a new trailer for it chapter two
to give you nightmares
for the rest of the week as long as you
don't fall asleep Pennywise can't get
you jokes on them it's comic-con week
nobody sleeps during comic-con week so
you should all be safe we'll break all
these Easter eggs down this is right out
of the books they added a couple really
big scenes that I'll explain that we're
not in the books but it's about 90%
adaptation from Stephen King's original
book if you're new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the
comic-con videos we're doing giveaways
all week long there's gonna be way more
big trailers coming this weekend but we
start off with the reunion of the losers
Club James McAvoy playing Bill Jessica
Chastain playing Beverly Bill Hader
playing Richie Jay Ryan playing Ben
remember he's the one that wrote the
love letter to Beverly for which bill
got credit we saw the letter when she
went back to her childhood home and she
runs into mrs. Kirsch and it turns into
this big Pennywise hallucination you
think that he might get credit for that
in present day like oh no you're the one
that sent the letter but nope as you
could see from the trailer Beverly and
Bill totally pick up where they left off
when the story begins because this is
happening 27 years later they all live
in different cities and they didn't wind
up getting together so both Beverly and
Bill are in different relationships at
the beginning of the story
nobody really keeps in touch that much
Mike the person who has the dialogue at
the beginning of the trailer is the
person that has to call them back to
fulfill their oath it has to remind them
about what happened there's this weird
proximity effect as part of Penny wises
power the further away from his lair and
dairy that you travel and the longer
time goes by the more you forget so most
of the losers Club has forgotten the
events of the first film except for Mike
who stayed in Derry and tells them
everything that happens so that it all
comes rushing back so a lot of that
happens really early in the film were
there like what did we did why we make
this oath what was this all about the
actual first time that they meet back up
is that restaurant scene that they sort
of break up in different parts during
the trailer where Pennywise starts
taunting them they showed off three
really long scenes at Comic Con two of
them are brand-new scenes that did not
appear in the book but the restaurant
scene is right off the page this
happened exactly the same way in the
book the two big scenes that did not
appear in the books are the ones where
they go back to the haunted house
the first film I'll talk about that in a
second because there's a whole bunch of
footage from that later in the trailer
and one of the big carnival scenes with
bill trying to chase down the little kid
and save him but you get that Mike
voiceover talking about remembering
everything and they start to intercut
with scenes from the first film with
Bill and Beverly being together their
story in present-day when you actually
see them for the first time is
interesting because it's all about the
psycho repeating this second film like
things are not over we're gonna have to
replay the events of the first film
I'll be with a couple big changes and as
part of that idea a lot of the problems
that they suffered from the personal
problems and the battles that they were
facing like Beverly trying to deal with
her abusive father also carried forward
into present day and a lot of them are
having the same types of problems so
Beverly in an abusive relationship as a
little kid has gotten herself into
another abusive relationship as an adult
like you see all these bruises all over
her arm it's just another sign that she
hasn't been able to escape her past like
the losers Club has not been able to
escape Pennywise as Mike's narration
continues you go downtown you see the
walls covered plastered with missing
posters of little children if you zoom
in you can see Georgie's face on one of
the posters here bill goes back to his
childhood home just like Beverly went
back to her childhood home he has a very
similar type of hallucination where he
sees the same drain with what looks like
Georgie's arms sticking out the reason
that happens is is that because everyone
that Pennywise captures is destined to
be his servant for all time so until
they finally defeat Pennywise anyone
that he's fully consumed is free to come
back and torment any of the losers Club
remember the reason why they couldn't
save Georgie at the end of the first
film even though they were able to
injure penny wise is because too much
time had gone by and penny wise had
already fully consumed Georgie's so
there was no more body left to be saved
like the ones that were hanging in his
thrall waiting to finish being consumed
by penny wise because he sort of
consumes them psychically and then
consumes them physically to gain their
sustenance we'll explain the physics of
penny wise in a second too because it's
critical to how they defeat him during
the movie there's a shot of the sewers
from the first film that they all
eventually have to go back to the water
coming around the corner reminds you of
the elevator scene from The Shining also
very famous Stephen King story that was
turned into a movie
Stanley coupe
actually changed the end of that with
the hedge maze Stephen King famously
hated the movie but in present day he
actually really liked the last
adaptation of the it movies so in his
old age he's much happier about the way
Hollywood is treating his material now
as opposed to when they were doing it
back during the 70s so it sort of led to
this even broader Stephen King
Renaissance where Hollywood is just
rushing to adapt his material Amazon is
working on a Dark Tower TV series
they're still doing Castle Rock someone
is getting ready to remake the stand as
a new TV series they've been announcing
the cast for that and then a couple
other big projects but they're also
making a sequel to The Shining or they
made one with you and McGregor playing
the little boy who's now an adult so it
is a really good time to be a big
Stephen King fan I'll do some Dark Tower
episode videos when that eventually
drops but I think it's gonna be a year
or two before we actually see that TV
series the sewer water scene transitions
to a different scene outside of a man
from the beginning of the movie who gets
pushed off a bridge during this big
balloon scene where you see all these
balloons coming up the bridge this is
when Pennywise comes back for the first
time in the movie this is probably from
the very very beginning of the film
there's some rednecks committing a hate
crime during the festival they throw
this guy off the bridge he lands in the
water starts splashing around yelling
for help but look right there is
Pennywise to snatch him he disappears
with everyone on top of the bridge
assuming that he drowned and that's the
sign that Pennywise has returned we're
all the losers Club starts hallucinating
him you see them in present-day go back
to the same area near the sewer exit
from the end of the first film where
they made the pact standing promising to
return if he ever came back which they
intercut with the restaurant reunion
scene which I said is the first time
that they actually come back after
they've all answered the call like oh
hey we haven't seen each other in 27
years what was it that we did so long
ago and then mike has to remind them of
everything but you notice there's seven
chairs and there's only six of them
sitting around the table
that's because Stanley is the only
member of the group of the losers Club
that does not answer the call to come
back when they hear Pennywise has
returned he's played by Andy bean from
The Swamp Thing TV show that now
cancelled Swamp Thing TV show so when he
gets the call the Pennywise has come
back he's living this normal happy life
he has a successful business he has a
wife that he loves very much but when he
finds out
he calmly and quietly goes to the
bathroom and carves Pennywise name into
his wrists in the bathtub killing
himself that's where you see the it
written in blood on the wall here so
he's dead before they ever come back to
Derry but he does reappear in a scene
that they showed off a comic-con that
I'll explain in a second they transition
from them sitting in the circle around
the table to them standing in this
circle as children making the pact this
is actually critical for them defeating
Pennywise performing the ritual of shoot
from the books we actually saw footage
of that in the last trailer and you see
it again in this trailer with them
standing in the circle entering his
dimension where you see like all this
stuff flying around them that's them
between dimensions going to the place
where Pennywise originally came from
it's sort of this inner dimensional
space in the Stephen King universe going
by Dark Tower mythology if you've never
read The Dark Tower series it's sort of
this multiverse story that Stephen King
tells that ties together elements of all
of his other stories so the story of
Pennywise the losers Club is connected
to the stuff that's happening in the
Dark Tower universe which is connected
to Cujo Christine the stand every other
story The Shining the Stephen King has
done but then you get the carnival scene
a bill trying to save that young boy who
he sort of imprints as a Second Coming
of Georgie like I said Beverly goes back
to her childhood home bill goes back to
his childhood home they have a very
similar basement scene where it floods
up and he starts hallucinating Georgie
who's now become penny wise as servant
but the little boy lives there with his
family so when he sees him later at the
carnival he tries to save them he chases
him down but they wind up in the
funhouse with all these creepy looking
clowns as you would expect there's a
mere maze that Pennywise then
manipulates tormenting bill that he
can't save this little kid and you get
his tongue sticking out and this really
creepy scene that was one of the scenes
they showed off a comic-con that did not
appear in the books but then you see
them going back to the interest of the
sewers you start to get penny wises
narration telling them how pissed off he
is so penny wise comes back and he has
been so mad for the last 27 years that
they were almost able to defeat him then
you get the other brand new scene that
did not appear in the books of them
coming back to the haunted house and
present-day intercut with them at the
house in the past so this is more of
them starting to remember the events of
the first film because
at the beginning of the story they still
forgotten everything you then see an
adult Henry Bowers the psychopath from
the first film at a mental hospital as
he also recognized penny wisest red
balloon going by that he's returned
remember penny wise brainwashed him in
the first film to become his agent to
try and stop the losers Club from coming
to Penny wisest lair in the sewers so
now that the losers Club has come back
in present-day penny wise reactivates so
to speak Henry helps him escape from the
mental prison and then they have to face
Henry Bowers and present-day again
there's a whole bunch of footage of them
in the haunted house I love the scene to
the three doors which isn't us wink at
the one from the first film not scary at
all scary and very scary spoiler warning
they're all scary anytime you see doors
like this in a creepy haunted house
anything behind them is going to be
scary the scene of the fridge shaking
very obviously something that penny wise
is getting ready to reveal was one of
the longer scenes they showed off at
Comic Con during this scene the fridge
opens to reveal their dead friends
Stanley that killed himself at the
beginning of the film is all part of
Penny wises manipulations just messing
with him there's the scene of the Paul
Bunyan statue with Pennywise floating
over it completely freaking Ritchie out
that's right out of the book in the book
the statue actually comes to life and
takes a swipe at him with his giant axe
they repeat all those scenes from the
last trailer with Beverly going back to
her childhood home she lived in with her
abusive father now occupied by mrs.
Kirsch who winds up being Pennywise
totally messing with her there's a
really creepy scene of Beverly getting
trapped in the bathroom in the bathtub
completely filling trying to drown her
with blood all these scenes towards the
end of the trailer of them going back to
Penny wises layer is from towards the
end of the film you see them step into
his actual there that's the barrier
where they transitioned to his dimension
then they ended the trailer on this very
cool scene of penny wise appearing to
them almost physically like he's
transitioning out of a painting like
he's that person transitioning into
penny wise but let me know in the
comments which our favorite part of the
trailer and any Easter eggs that I did
not mention in the video like I said
about 90% of this and their big action
scenes are right off of the page with a
couple big additions but I'll be doing
Comic Con videos all weekend we have The
Witcher trailer Rick and Morty season
four whole bunch of stuff coming
tomorrow and then Saturday is the big
Marvel page
with marble phase for stuff and a bunch
of DC stuff so as long as you have
alerts enabled for my channel you'll see
the videos when I post them and I'll
name a giveaway winner when I post my
next video click here for that brand new
Thor 4 teaser and click here for that
brand new Avengers and game deleted
scenes video thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
we all float at comic-con
[Music]